[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Terry is
with us in Tampa Florida hi Carrie how
are you
hi Dave oh my goodness it's an honor to
be on your show honored to have you how
can we help
so I I'm really just looking for debt
advice
we are struggling to
uh payments for my husband's franchise
that is now closed
ouch
yeah how much you borrowed it you
borrowed how much on an SBA loan to buy
a franchise
we um it was a total of 223 thousand
dollars
what kind of franchise it was a moving
company
he kind of bought it at a premium
because it was already in existence and
and we really were under the impression
it would be successful and unfortunately
I don't know if it was just due to the
market at the time but
um it was really obvious after about a
year that it was it was not going to be
profitable
um anytime soon and so he was made the
decision to close it and it was a big it
was a big risk to begin with but um we
decided to go ahead and just close it
and move on
um he does have a great job now that he
loves things what does he make but
about 70 000 now what do you make
I make 48 000.
do you guys have any other debt
we don't well we have a very small car
loan remaining and our house payment
um
we have about 200 000 left on our house
are there any assets at all left over
from the business
from the business no you sold them or
what
yes everything was sold and wiped out
um the actual franchise itself is is the
is the brand still open
yes can you not sell that franchise to
someone
no it wasn't going to be and no it
they
couldn't help us with that
wow why
um that's a good question I would
we we asked the question at the time and
it was going to be a a very very long
process to even try to find a buyer and
I don't know and honestly it just
I assume the franchisor has approval
over any buyer but even if you could
sell the thing for ten thousand bucks to
somebody that just wanted that franchise
because they're probably selling that
franchise to a brand new Frenchie
franchisee for a good deal more than
that correct
it's possible they they kind of just
in there so you've lost your rights to
it by now then probably yeah yes it was
closed we closed it in in February now
closing it is different than the actual
franchise a franchise is an element
that is actually a a right that you have
that you paid for
um right all right so it was it has
expired us involved man well so you got
233 000 on 110.
yeah twenty three thousand dollars a
year is ten years
fifty thousand dollars a year it's five
years
what are you gonna do to get your income
up so it goes faster
all right I'm not sure we're hoping
um we're hoping that his job so far it's
going well but what did he do before
this promotion uh he's an operations and
Logistics management he's worked for
um he's worked for Amazon for a few
years and he worked for another company
for a few years
um what did he make before he quit and
started the franchise
he was making about one I want 109 109.
that sounds more like Logistics than 70.
yes yes and he lost that job and
in 2021
they had a lot of they had a a
restructuring in the in the businesses
yeah but the logistics world if he know
if he if he knows supply chain and he
knows how to lay that out that's a
six-figure income
yes you would you would think that no I
wouldn't think I know but right right
and you live in Tampa freaking Florida
there's Logistics there for sure
let me tell you Carrie here's what's
going on okay you guys got the crap beat
out of you and your husband's lost his
confidence and you have too
and he doesn't feel like he's worth what
he's actually worth
because of this failure
I need you guys for your sake to go get
him a job making 110. he needs to get
back in the marketplace with his
shoulders thrown back and a little
Swagger in his step again he's not a bad
guy he just made you guys just made a
mistake and bought a business that you
didn't know how to run and run it in the
ground and you've lost your butts but
that doesn't mean you're horrible people
or you're dumb people or that suddenly
he's not worth 110 when he probably
actually is
at least one of the things I had to
recover from when I went broke and mine
was a lot more dramatic although there's
you know what is major surgery surgery
that happens to you what's minor surgery
surgery happened to somebody else right
so um yours is very dramatic for you I'm
sure and traumatic but one of the things
I had to recover from was I felt like an
idiot
I felt like I know why should anybody
trust anything I ever think again
because I was so stinking arrogant
before it knocked me completely out of
the saddle
and um I don't think your husband was
that guy but but it's normal when you go
through this it's the death of a dream
and part of your soul dies when you
close that door and lock the turn the
key for the last time and walk away
that definitely sounds weird yeah yeah
and I I just I I want to give you
permission to grieve that but I also uh
want you to to to keep perspective on it
and him to keep perspective on it
because I think he took just something
to get a job and he's just kind of
curled up in the corner uh wounded right
now
we definitely we definitely went through
that
um we are hopeful for this job I mean he
he applied for jobs for almost a year
before he decided to open a franchise
we're not we're on the outskirts of
Tampa we're not really in Tampa so we
weren't finding anything
um at all
um and so when this this opportunity
currently that he's working for came
along
um
he's really really enjoying the job and
we're hoping well I'm glad but you have
223 000 worth of debt and he needs to
make a lot more yeah well my my okay
that's how it's going to be done kiddo
I'm not gonna argue with you anymore
okay the thing is I understand where you
are I've been where you are I and I'm
sorry that you've been through all this
pain
um but yeah we we you know you've got a
the big math says you need to put fifty
thousand dollars a year on it and you
can do that with your current income if
you live on beans and rice and it's
going to take you five years
or you can increase your income by forty
thousand dollars and do this in three or
four years and not have to live on beans
and rice while you're doing it and I I
really think that there's a tie in here
you look when you get hit this hard you
look for a safe place to hide and human
nature does that you want to go back to
something where I'm you know no risk no
like just I don't stick my head up I'll
get it knocked off again you know I
don't want to do that so thank you for
your call that's the answer you take the
223 and you divide it into the number of
years you want to fool with this and
what have you got to do what has to be
true to make that happen and part of
that is healing from this the rest of
the way and
um you're making excuses you are and
part of that tells me you haven't healed
from this the rest of the way so you
shouldn't have asked if you didn't want
me to tell you that's true and guys let
me just tell you those of you in
business out there well business debt
doesn't count business debt is good debt
tell that to carry
all right you go take out a two hundred
thousand dollar loan to buy a business
you're in stupid land and you do that
with an SBA loan you're in super stupid
land because SBA is forever they do not
go away they're like a student loan and
I'm not saying Kerry's stupid I'm just
saying any of you that are thinking
about doing this you need to listen to
her call
because oh well I am We're Not Gonna
yeah well right Dad only works when debt
works and that's never
you get your butt bit off here man
people you got to stop it you got to
stop it ouch